I'm gonna start by just pointing out some
of the symbolism in the movie, then at the
end I'll piece it all together and let you
know how the religious subplot ties into the
surface level story about the author and his
wife.
Let me start off by saying that different
audiences are going to have different interpretations
of this movie.
This is just my interpreation, so if your
view on the movie isn't the same as mine...
THEN SCREW YOU, IDIOT.
So with that all out of the way, I see the
movie as a representation of The Exodus.
Long story short, back in the day the Israelites
were enslaved by the Pharaoh in Egypt.
There was this dude named Moses.
God hits him up and says he's going to drop
these plagues on the Egyptians to force them
to let his people go.
There were 10 Plagues in all.
These events are the basis for the Jewish
holiday, Passover.
Each of these 10 plagues are represented in
Darren Aronofsky's film.
The first plague was the plague of blood.
In the Exodus, all the water in Egypt is turned
into blood -- in mother!
the two brothers barge into the house and
start arguing about their father's will.
This leads to a physical fight resulting in
a death.
The living room, or in this case, the dying
room, is covered in a pool of blood, and no
matter what Jennifer Lawrence does, she can't
get the blood to fully go away, much like
another horror movie that came out this year.
The blood seeps down into the cellar, and
follows this path along the wall, which shows
us that this isn't just a regular leak, there
is something of a divine interference.
This part may or may not be related, but when
the water in Egypt was turned to blood, the
Egyptians suffered from terrible thirst.
When Ed Harris gets to the house, Jennifer
Lawrence offers him some tea, she gets back
from making it to find that they've already
broken into a flask of alcohol, not to mention
Michelle Pfeiffer's crazy obsession with making
lemonade.
So this could mirror the thirst of the Egyptians.
The basement is the setting for the appearance
of several of the plagues.
I also like the idea of the blood being something
that is literally sent from above, and in
the Exodus, the Egyptians tried digging into
the ground to find water, only to find more
blood, similar to how Jennifer goes underground
into the basement and finds more blood there
was well.
It's also worth noting that Moses makes the
blood first appear by striking the Nile river
with a wooden staff, and the blood in mother!
appears after the brother strikes his sibling
with a wooden chair.
The second plague is frogs.
The Egyptians' houses were invaded by these
swarms of frogs.
Right after she goes into the basement to
follow the blood, there is this wall that
she breaks away and it leads her to a secret
area, where she finds a frog living in her
basement.
It wasn't a swarm of frogs, but it's just
more of a subtle reference.
Plus, where there is one amphibian, there
are usually more to be found.
The only plague that I'm not entirely sure
about is the third one, which is lice / bugs.
It's likely that this plague is represented
somewhere in the movie considering that the
other 9 are accounted for but I wasn't really
looking out for them when watching this for
the first time.
If you have ideas about this one, let me know
in the comments, I'd love to fill in that
missing piece.
But anyway, the fourth plague is accounted
for.
When Javier Bardem offers to hold the wake
for the deceased son of Ed Harris, the house
is overrun by seemingly tons of random guests
and these guests represent the horde of wild
beasts.
In the Exodus passage, the beasts are described
as wild animals that rove all over the country
and destroy everything that they have built.
Our two main characters have spent their marriage
renovating this house together and these people
literally roam in in hordes and destroy what
they have built together.
The fifth plague involved a disease that killed
all of the Egyptians' livestock.
Jennifer and Javier aren't shown to have any
livestock, but there is a scene in the kitchen
where she sees a dying bee keel over and pass
away.
This is the most relevant modern world parallel
to diseased livestock.
Beekeeping is an industry where colonies are
maintained by man in order to collect and
sell the natural products that the bee produces,
one that has been threatened in recent years
by a mysterious disease killing up to 50%
of bees.
In this case, bees represent the livestock
of these beekeepers and the colony collapse
disorder is a modern day plague against them.
The sixth plague was boils, which manifest
the first night that Ed Harris stays over
at the house.
He gets sick and Jennifer Lawrence hears him
coughing as she is trying to get to sleep.
She gets up to see if everything is alright
and finds her husband tending to him.
He is coughing and vomiting over the toilet
and seems to be covered in painful looking
boils.
When she asks him about it the next day, he
claims to be fine.
In addition to that, here is the actual quote
from the Exodus passage: "Take handfuls of
soot from a furnace and have Moses toss it
into the air in the presence of Pharaoh.
It will become fine dust over the whole land
of Egypt, and festering boils will break out
on men and animals throughout the land."
— Exodus 9:8–9
The movie has a strong emphasis on the furnace
in the basement.
At first I thought it was a throwback to the
refrigerator in Aronofsky's 2000 film, Requiem
for a Dream, just because of the fact that
it's a large appliance that makes noises that
scare her and at that point in the film it
seemed like it was possibly a hallucination.
However, looking back on it, there may have
been a deeper significance.
Later in the movie, we actually see this furnace
soot stuff being plastered on Javier Bardem's
followers.
The seventh plague is a thunderstorm of hail.
Again, this isn't represented with a literal
halestorm, but rather a scaled down representation.
This comes up during the wake scene, and despite
Jennifer Lawrence's constant requests, people
keep sitting on her sink countertop, which
has not yet been reinforced.
Eventually, the counter snaps, the pipe breaks
and a storm of water sprays up and begins
flooding the house, creating complete chaos.
Jennifer Lawrence even refers to the mess
created by these people as an "apocalypse",
a reference to the apocalyptic conditions
of the aforementioned hailstorm.
[Clip]
No, not that halestorm.
Moving right along plague 8, we have the locusts.
After the thunderstorm, God's message for
Pharaoh, was this:
"If you refuse to let them go, I will bring
locusts into your country tomorrow.
They will cover the face of the ground so
that it cannot be seen.
They will devour what little you have left
after the hail...
They will fill your houses and those of all
your officials and all the Egyptians."
— Exodus 10:3–6
I see the representation of the locusts in
mother!
to be the fans of Javier Bardem.
They invade the house, literally to the point
that the floor cannot be seen.
They devour all of the food, including the
meal that Jennifer Lawrence had just prepared,
and they take everything that remains, ripping
the house apart to get a piece of their hero's
life.
That situation continues to devolve until
there is a full on war taking place in the
house, complete with soldiers and riot police.
It is at this point that Jennifer Lawrence
is temporarily blinded, she gets sprayed in
the face with pepper spray.
Enter plague number 9: Darkness.
And of course, this all culminates with the
tenth and final plague: Death of the first
born.
Jennifer Lawrence finally delivers her baby,
Javier Bardem gives it to the people, their
careless actions lead to the baby's neck snapping.
Now that I've identified the 10 plagues, or
at least 9 of the 10, I'll let the director,
Darren Aronofsky, explain the roles of the
characters and their relationship to the religious
figures.
"Using to tell the stories of humanity, the
stories of the bible.
Ed and Michelle are the first man and woman,
and these are the sons.
And you can probably then figure out who Javier
is from that last shot."
So with that in mind, let's take a look back
at the scene in the study.
When Ed Harris first sees the... uh...
I'm just gonna call it the shiny object, he
is captivated by it.
He feels this need to hold it, to touch it,
but Javier tells him that the shiny object
is very precious to him and forbids him from
touching it, going so far as to say no guests
will be allowed in the study while he is not
in there.
The shiny object is our metaphorical apple
of Eden, but Ed and Michelle, being the Adam
and Eve that they are go in there anyway and
break it, and then God is pretty upset and
he forever bans them from the Garden of Eden
by boarding off the area with hammer and nails.
They retreat to their room and the next time
we see them, they are doing it.
Next thing you know, they have kids, who show
up to the house, Cain and Abel.
Cain is the older brother, thought to be the
originator of all things evil and violent,
so shoutout to him, he slays his younger brother
Abel, and the family proceeds to grieve, and
it's during this time that they turn to God
/ Javier Bardem, who gives a speech at the
wake that offers them hope.
This leads to him gaining a huge following
and these people become his worshippers.
He writes a holy scripture...
aka: his book.
However, some of them are led astray, and
worship a false idol, which we see when people
are worshipping a photo, or his possessions,
rather than the real thing.
That's kind of where the 10 Plagues thing
comes in.
The Egyptians worship the Pharaoh, a false
God, while Jews worship their one only.
The Jewish people escape Egypt, are promised
the Holy Land of Israel by God, but there
are also the Palestinians who also claim the
divine right to that land.
So a huge fight breaks out, which we see in
the movie, starting as the followers of Javier
arguing over who gets to be in the house,
which eventually becomes who gets his possessions,
and continues to devolve into a full blown
war zone representative of the ongoing Israeli-Palestine
conflict.
Finally, Jennifer has the baby and all of
Javier's followers are waiting outside to
see the newborn.
You could look at this as the birth of Christianity,
with the baby being Jesus and dying for the
people's sins, or you could examine Jennifer's
actions, sheltering the baby for many days
and nights, asking Javier, the Pharaoh, the
false God, to make those people go before
he holds the child.
Very similar to Moses asking Pharaoh to let
my people go and also aligning with the Torah
story of the Israelites escaping from Egypt
and wandering the desert for 40 years to let
the generation that was tainted by Pharaoh
die off so that a new, pure generation could
enter the promised land.
The new iteration of the cycle could represent
a new beginning in that promised land.
Or it could represent the opening of a new
book, the new testament.
It all depends how you look at it.
And I think that's the point.
As with real life, there are different people
with different beliefs, and this is the cause
for different religions.
That's my interpretation of the subtext, but
what does it have to do with the surface level
story -- the one about a writer and his wife
trying to have a baby?
I think Aronofsky is comparing our current
celebrity crazed culture to the worship of
false idols.
When Ed Harris gets to the house, he poses
as a doctor who has lost his way looking for
a place to stay.
Jennifer later finds a picture of her husband
in the man's bag from the about me section
of one of his books.
The man confesses to being a superfan who
came out just to see Javier before he passes
away.
Javier says that it's nice to have someone
who appreciates his writing, to which Jennifer
responds, "I love your work."
This creates the divide between someone who
loves him for who he is and someone who worships
the idea of him, his celebrity persona.
Ed becomes so enthralled by his idol that
he brings his wife along to meet him.
After the unfortunate passing of the man's
son, Javier offers hospitality and words of
wisdom in front of a large group of people
and his cult following grows.
After releasing his next scripture, he has
fans waiting outside his house to meet him,
and before long, that turns into breaking
into his house, people fighting over him,
tossing all of their morals for a chance to
meet him.
Aronofsky is commenting on how modern obsession
over celebrities has become like a religious
craze.
People worship these celebrities and look
at the damage that it causes.
As far as I noticed, not one of the characters
in the movie is given an actual name, so we
have to refer to them using the name of the
actor, as I have throughout this entire video.
This practice feeds into the whole idolisation
of celebrities.
People are so obsessed with these actors that
they ignore everything else.
Have you ever referred to a movie character
in conversation, not been able to remember
the name and said something like "the Jennifer
Lawrence-character"?
By not giving the characters names, this is
exactly the behaviour that Aronofsky is trying
to highlight.
Look up mother!
on Google right now.
You'll notice several articles referring to
the movie as Jennifer Lawrence's new movie
mother!
As you know by now, the film was directed
by Darren Aronofsky.
Not Jennifer Lawrence.
But speaking of Jennifer Lawrence, what an
ideal candidate for a movie about the damage
caused by the obsession of celebrities.
A few years ago she had her iCloud hacked
and nude photos leaked to the internet in
an incident known as the Fappening.
To be entirely transparent though, she may
have just been casted because she's sleeping
with the director.
Literally, she is.
By the way, if this video has helped you appreciate
the movie a little bit more, go ahead and
leave a like on this video.
If you are a fan of psychological thrillers,
go ahead and check out this nightmare horror
story video I wrote.
And if you missed yesterday's Deadstream here's
a link to that as well.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week.
Ring that deathbell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one one.
Assuming we both survive.